ASA DOTZLER: Thank you
for the introduction
and for the invitation.
Hello, my name is Asa Dotzler.
I'm a Mozillian.
I've been with Mozilla
for about 15 years now.
My business card says
storyteller and spokesmodel,
but my real work at Mozilla
has been mostly nontechnical
and mostly focused
on lowering barriers
to participation in
Mozilla projects.
I'm sure most of you know, but
there may be a few of you who
don't.
So I'll tell you a
little bit about Mozilla.
Mozilla is a nonprofit
organization.
Our shareholders are the
people of planet Earth,
the several billion
people who are already
developing, participating in,
and consuming web experiences,
and the 5 or 6
billion more that will
come online over the
next decade or so.
We do a lot of
things at Mozilla,
but we're most well known
for the Firefox web browser
and more recently for a
mobile operating system
called Firefox OS.
Like everything we do,
Firefox and Firefox OS
are open-source software.
In addition to being
licensed open source,
there are also open projects.
We focus a lot of
attention on making sure
that our projects are
approachable and participatory.
From the initial planning
stages through development
and support, from the top of the
stack the bottom of the stack,
everything we do is meant to be
open, approachable, accessible,
and participatory.
That means that I don't have any
secrets to reveal here, today,
any new product announcements
or anything like that.
And virtually
everything I say you
can find behind one
of these three links.
I hope that that
doesn't disappoint,
and I hope that
the talk is still
valuable for a
whole bunch of you.
In the next 10 or
15 minutes, I'm
going to share with
you the work we've
done to bring WebRTC
to our browsers
over the last couple years,
our ongoing work to put WebRTC
into the Firefox OS
mobile operating system.
And I'm going to give
you a brief introduction
to an application we're building
into Firefox, the browser,
and Firefox OS--
currently code named
Loop-- that will give consumers,
give users of the product
a chat experience.
I don't need to go into
the full history of WebRTC
because you all got a great
briefing in the earlier
first couple of sessions.
But one year ago
this week, Mozilla
shipped Firefox Version
22 on the desktop
to Mac, Windows, and Linux
with the full WebRTC stack,
that is, getUserMedia,
PeerConnection,
and DataChannel.
Two releases after that,
about three months later,
we added the full stack
to our Android browser
so that we had-- Gecko
is Gecko is Gecko.
Our web run time inside of our
desktop browser Mac, Windows
and Linux, and our
Android mobile browser all
run the same software,
virtually the same software,
and you should get the same
experiences out of them.
We started on the desktop
for a couple of reasons.
A lot of people ask why we
didn't start on mobile first,
where everyone else is.
The first reason is the
desktop had the horsepower.
A couple of years ago, mobile
wasn't where it is today.
The processing power made a
big difference-- connectivity
of Wi-Fi versus less solid
connectivity on mobile devices
as well as the fact that Google
was starting its implementation
on the desktop and pushing
mobile till later as well.
And so we worked with Google
and the Chrome team quite a bit
to develop the WebRTC standards
and to design and build
an interoperable
WebRTC implementation
between the Chrome browsers
and the Firefox browsers.
I think this is really
important as we demonstrate
that the web is about
multivendor solutions.
And the fact that we
could produce WebRTC video
chats from the Chrome browser
to the Firefox browser
over a year ago
is, I think, proof
that WebRTC is on
its way to becoming
a fundamental
component of the web.
After the desktop
and the mobile work,
we moved on to integrating
Firefox-- sorry, WebRTC
into Firefox OS.
How many people
here are familiar
with our mobile
operating system?
And how many people are
familiar with the architecture
of our mobile operating system?
So I'll start there real quick.
Firefox OS is an open-source
mobile operating system.
And what we've
done here is we've
taken the Linux kernel
and Howl and other drivers
down to the various low level.
We packaged that up into
a module we called Gonk.
I call it Gonk.
It's all the ugly stuff I
don't like to think about.
But above that, we dropped
Gecko onto it right on top.
There's no in-between layer.
We drop our web run
time right on top
of the kernel and drivers.
And above that,
we've built using
web languages-- all pure
HTML, JavaScript, CSS,
the things you know and love--
a series of system components
and applications that ship
on Firefox OS mobile phones.
This includes things
like our start screen,
a dialer-- you need a dialer on
a phone-- address book, camera,
interfaces, all of
these kinds of things.
Firefox OS is a web
native platform.
I hear a lot of people talk
about the native stacks
out there and the web
versus the native stacks.
I'm just old enough
to remember when
Java wasn't really
considered a native stack.
It was a plug-in to the browsers
or a server side technology.
And with Firefox OS,
what we're trying to do
is assert that JavaScript,
HTML, CSS, and friends
are the native platform.
They are as close to the
metal as we can get them,
as highly tuned and
performant as we can get them.
And the purpose of building
this new architecture
in this new product
is because we
think the web is the greatest
platform ever invented
and that the next 4, 5 6
billion people who come online
are going to be coming
online and experiencing that
through mobile devices, first.
And we want the web
to be a first class
citizen on those mobile devices.
Mozilla employees, our global
community of tens of thousands
of volunteers, and a bunch of
Firefox OS ecosystem partners,
these are the people
who are building
the handsets, the carriers and
operators, our retail partners,
all work together in the
open to build Firefox OS.
One of the unique aspects
of this development
is that any of you can
be involved as well.
We don't batch up a
whole bunch of changes
and toss them over the wall
every three or six months.
Everything we do, like I said,
from design to implementation
from the top to the
bottom of the stack
is open and participatory
from day one.
But mobile and the web have
had a tricky relationship
over the last four
or five years.
And one of the major
reasons for that
is that mobile
browsers are what we
think of when we think
of mobile and the web.
And the mobile browsers have
typically been fairly crippled.
If you look at the browsers on
iOS over the last few years,
you didn't get any of the
really nice JavaScript
performance out of it.
I think Apple's rectifying that.
Google is also bringing some
of that really nice performance
to upcoming versions of Android.
But with Firefox
OS, where we don't
have to think about it
in terms of a browser,
and we can actually deliver
the full capability of the web
platform without any of
the legacy of what you need
to put on to something
to make it a browser,
we were able to achieve some
pretty significant performance
wins.
And on top of that,
we started closing
the gap between the
actual device capabilities
available to you in
the native stacks
and those available to
you in the web stack.
We did this through a
project called Web API.
Web API is everything
we know and love
from the last 20 years of
web development from HTML
and JavaScript and CSS.
But it's also a new class of
APIs that will fill those gaps.
The pieces of hardware, the
sensors and the services
and other capabilities that
we find on mobile devices
that we don't typically
find on desktops and laptops
should all be
accessible through APIs
that are comfortable familiar
and accessible to web
developers.
And that's what we're building
into Firefox OS today.
And we've got 30 or
40 of these going.
All of them are intended to
be standardized, ultimately.
And a few of them are available
in the desktop browser
to try out.
A few of them are available
on our mobile browser.
But the real focus of the
web API development effort
is in Firefox OS, which
is available for download
and testing just as
the Firefox browser is.
So where are we with
Firefox OS and WebRTC?
We shipped our first version
of Firefox OS about a year ago.
It was a year and a half
ago that we declared
Version 1.0 done, but
it was about a year
before our partners were able to
get those devices into market.
That went into about 15 markets.
That is up to about 35 today.
And by the end of
this year, I think
we're closer to 40 markets.
I'll have to double
check on that.
Sorry, we'll be up
to 30 geographies
by the end of this year.
We shipped Firefox
OS Version 1.3
at the beginning of this year.
It's the current
in-market newest release.
And all of our team are hard
at work on Firefox 2.0 and 2.1.
2.0 is where we
introduce WebRTC.
We've had some pieces-- I
think we had getUserMedia there
for a little while.
But Firefox OS
Version 2.0, which
is wrapping up in the
next couple of months
and hitting devices in market
by the end of this year, maybe
mid fourth quarter, will have
getUserMedia PeerConnection
and DataChannel, and
an implementation that
should be highly compatible--
given that this is the Gecko
stack-- with our Mac, Windows,
Linux and Android browser
views.
And that should
make it really easy
for you to take the work
you've done on WebRTC apps
and to deploy those to any of
the Firefox or Chrome browsers
out there as well as with
only hopefully minor changes,
packaging them up and shipping
them as Firefox OS apps.
In addition, you can also load
up the browser inside a Firefox
OS and treat it just as
a regular web-based app.
We've still got a lot
of bugs to iron out,
and we're especially focused
on performance optimizations.
As you move to mobile and as
you move into the Firefox OS
mobile space, which is targeting
the mid-tier and low end
of the market and not the Hero
phones with 8-core processors
and running at 2.5
gigahertz, but more
like these $100 to
$150 devices that
have a dual-core processor
and 512 megs of RAM.
So getting into those
spaces with performance
is our big challenge and
where most of our effort
is right now.
But we think we've made
some really good progress,
and we'd love for you
all to check that out.
Once again, we're
working very hard
to make sure that Gecko
is Gecko is Gecko.
Whether you're hitting
on a desktop browser,
a mobile browser,
or Firefox OS, when
you develop a WebRTC application
or solution for our platform,
it should work on all
of these form factors.
I'm going to wrap with a
little bit of information
on a project that's
pretty new to Mozilla.
And this is to take a bunch of
the work we've done in WebRTC,
which empowers you all in
our developer community
to build great experiences,
and surface some of that
to our users of
the Firefox browser
and of the Firefox OS
mobile operating system.
We want to build an actual
app, a user experience that
will let people very quickly
and easily chat between them
and their friends
on their browsers
and in an app on the
mobile operating system.
Right now, Loop is very
early in development.
It's meant to be quick an easy.
We're not trying
to-- I don't believe
we're trying to take
on any of the highly
successful, commercial video
chat applications out there.
We want to make it super simple.
And so the first implementation
looks kind of like this.
You'll open up your
Firefox web browser.
You'll click on a
little chat icon,
and it will give you
a URL to yourself.
You give that to your friend.
Your friend clicks on it.
You get a little pop-up "accept
call from friend," say yes,
and you get a
video pop-up window
that floats in
your browser on top
of the tab you're
currently viewing.
You can pop that out into
a free standing window.
You can go full screen.
You can navigate all
your other browser tabs
and move between Windows, and
the call continues and stays
functional.
And that allows you
to surf around the web
while you're talking
to one of your friends.
That's an anonymous experience.
We're also working to integrate
with Firefox accounts,
and that will allow
you to communicate
to people via their Firefox
account email addresses.
It will also give you the
opportunity to store an address
book, import, edit and store
address book information,
to set who can and
cannot call you.
Maybe we'll have like
auto answer or block
answers for certain people
that are calling you too often.
And then all of this will
be similarly packaged up
and deployed as an application
that users can download,
install, and run on
Firefox OS devices.
So it is basic and it
is anonymous today.
We're growing out the
further functionality.
I think you can get
a look at this today.
There's a URL up here
that will give you
all the architectural
information about Loop
as well as some of the
design documentation.
And I think it's a
nightly build of Firefox.
So any of you who are on the
very tip of our development
there can get a good look at it
through the Firefox web browser
nightly channel.
And as I come to the
conclusion, here,
I want to wrap with something
that one of my good friends,
Maire Reavy, our media
goddess at Mozilla
and one of the core
members of the WebRTC team.
Please help us bring real-time
communications to the web.
We're not done yet.
We need your help to build great
applications and experiences.
We need your help in feedback
as we develop the APIs
and work toward a next version
and additional capabilities.
We need you to report bugs
on our implementations
and our competitors'
implementations
and to seek out
interoperability and call us
out when we don't have it.
We need you to help
us test and develop.
With your help, and your
ideas, and your enthusiasm,
we're going to take the
web to a whole new level.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]